okay hello everyone welcome to
another woven language design session
incremental language development
a variety of topics head map and the
naming of it
so
head map
is something that
will take a
a list of heads and apply each of them
to
a result
you know to an input and give you the
list of results so it's sort of like
thread only
rather than giving you know f g of at
list f g of x
and thread that you give it the list f g
and then x
do you mean through itai
um yeah through rather than threads yes
through
yeah i misspoke
okay okay
i mean this function every single time i
hear its name i don't know what the hell
it does
so possible names let's go down here
again
why do we think it should have the word
head in the name
because normally takes a head and
arguments and applies the head to all
the arguments this is going to take
several heads and apply the heads to a
single argument but you could maybe call
it a function instead of a head but
function map is a little bit vague
yeah what about
map heads
i think it would what i would think that
meant was map onto the heads
i see right like map all maps to
everything
map at maps uh you know right
um
through applied
would through applied make sense
i think it just i think we talked about
this last time i think it just compounds
the bad name that is through
and there's also the question of if it's
var args or if you wrap the arguments in
a list and you have a level spec
if you wrap them in a list then apply it
makes more sense if you don't
there's
an applied is less
right
or if you just require that people use
apply you know the headdress apply if
they want to you know right but why
isn't
this
something
why isn't it something like this
that is one of the suggestions you have
there oh god we already had it there
but also also i think applied makes it
sound like one of these sort of
you know combinator operator applied
kind of things which you know this is
not exclusively in fact i think this
would be more useful
not in that context
to explain i mean you mean you mean as a
like you keep writing this as an
operator form but i think that it'll be
used more in its non-operator form like
both will be useful but but but this is
not at all like we have these functions
that are like they mostly live as
operator forms and then we have
functions right that just so happen to
have an operator form this is the second
category
right and also notice that
um
right it's it's it's right it's sort of
skipping part of the list there right
all applied would give you the list f of
right if you if you literally like g of
x yeah right
so in that sense it's sort of a
not really in the applied family which
you know why isn't this in the implied
family
right because those take what's inside
and use that as a head and you're going
to break this up
and use elements of it as a head
point
okay again what is this thing really
it's taking
i mean the case i imagine using or that
i've done something similar to this
where i occasionally use through is i
have a data set and i want the mean the
median the commonest the variance etc i
want to apply a number of functions to
the same set of data
so it i sort of think of it as a
multi-function but that name probably
has other baggage it has other other
things we're about to do with it
yeah i mean that's one usage another one
that that data set actually does
automatically
but which is useful outside of data says
if you have a composition chain and in
the middle of the composition chain you
want to apply two functions instead of
one so data set already does that
automatically if you put a list in the
middle of a composition chain in a query
in a data set it will apply both
functions and return them as a list but
right now if you
you know outside of a data set you have
to use through to do that in a very okay
so what are you saying so you're saying
something like this head map
gh
exactly yeah compose something else
right
okay and so now so what that will be is
yeah
all right does this
okay so if i now apply this to x
right
that's cool
that's really cool
that's a super useful operation if you
you know
yeah yeah
although in an operator form
that is the operator form yeah no i know
i know i know but it's going to this
name head map is just completely not
making it every time i look at it i
don't know what it means
uh
okay what is this thing doing it is it
is
and how does it think i think it's like
an evaluate list or an evaluate each
i mean i suppose we could go with a
playlist or apply each but it's right
it's not applied in the sense of apply
yes
it's it's more or possible
i think is nick here because but this is
is this in fact a multi-function
both nicks are here yes
oh okay then
nick without the c
in what sense is
i don't know i mean this this reminds me
of a of a monoidal category type story
like this is just it's a multi way in
the sense that it's applying all all the
functions you gave it sure yeah yeah
right so so so the thing that
takes f and x and gives you f of x
that's operate correct
whereas what f of f
yeah
right so should this be like construct
list or construct each
well so one of the questions we had last
time
um
although i think we were generally
leaning away from this was so with
construct if you say constructive f x
comma y
it's going to you know run f of x comma
y
and so one of the ideas with the head
map thing was that you know normally
with lists
you know the third argument is a level
spec but an alternative would be to make
head nap bear args
and you know it'll kind of
do something like what construct does
um
but i think
i think we were moving away from that
because that i think there was
one it seemed like slightly weird
behavior that you can easily get in
other ways and two
the level spec is a coherent
thing to have for head map and so it you
know
yeah yeah i don't think the verilog's
version is is particularly important
he says although i mean in this chain
no because in in original position yeah
yeah composition position just takes one
argument things generally unless it's
the last thing in the composition right
by the way all this stuff like
jonathan's category theory stuff
is in a sense potentially if i'm not i
mean
the
the monoidal category stuff i think
is a way in the string diagrams am i
right that string diagrams are related
to being able to do multi-argument
versions of of composition chains
i mean isn't it basically just you you
know you have this thing that that just
tells you which arguments go into which
other arguments
yes i mean which port it's going to yeah
right
so in a sense one of the things we could
imagine
is something like net graph
well but by the way i mean this this
this is otherwise i mean in programming
you represent the same concepts with
like variables and function application
sure
well except it's like this isn't really
uh like
i think there are existing ways to do
that no i understand but the point about
it is the concept of a disembodied
you know variable mapping you know a
disembodied graph
into which you feed functions so to
speak so imagine that you have which is
similar to the currying business
you know curry is another disembodied
meta you know
um sort of
pure bureaucracy pure routing function
you could you could easily have a
function that you'd call i i don't know
what you exactly would call it but it's
like a version of composition where you
give it two functions and then you give
it a permutation
and you know it'll use that permutation
to map the you know outputs of of one
function the inputs of the next or
something like that well assuming the
functions return lists
well you know or anything you can take
parts from but that's a lot of things
yeah but so okay so this is i.e knitting
together
functions that
take
lists as input
and give lists as output
well i thought the idea is they give
they take
well i was imagining as they take sort
of an argument input and then the other
one returns
something
entertaining and
i agree but the problem is that we have
a way of representing
you know the the the way of giving n
arguments is different from the way of
listing and things in output and i think
it could be simpler symmetrical
um
i mean but then that's just equivalent
to having composition where in the
middle of the composition you have
extract
it's just f compose extract compose g
well unless you have a thing where you
can uh skip a function
see what i'm saying
you're right if it's a series of blocks
that are one and one
after another but if you if you go i
think if you're skipping a function it's
going to be so complicated like this is
really just used variables
like that well no no no but that's
exactly what variables i know but but
the whole point is that we want to be
able to do this is the whole point of
this you know
monoidal categories net graph etc etc
etc and i think it's a i you know in
string diagrams i believe if i'm not
wrong
this is is this can somebody confirm
this is related to string diagrams
well it is if you're skipping a function
in the stream diagrams essentially means
you're using an identity
box or process whatever you want to call
it
right if you if you're composing a
function that has two outputs and with
the function that has only a single
input you can
it's equivalent as you have to have this
function
product horizontal product with identity
right
one of the outputs
how does this relate to what you've done
in the quantum framework
because that's the same thing you do
with tensors
you have tensors have inputs and outputs
it's covariant
yes and you represent it with steam
diagrams
yeah
but in our case
okay
how do we have i mean so this idea of
the pure
sort of knitting together of inputs and
outputs of functions
you know what i'm imagining is
a little bit like i don't know a
graphics complex
where you give the knitting and then you
give the payloads
does that make sense
so here you've given this you've done
that
it's a very it's a very unnatural way to
to code these things i mean this is why
i mean for example
you know this is like one of the ideas
of tensorflow so the way the tensorflow
works is i mean internally of course
there ends up being something like a net
graph eventually
um
but but with tensorflow you know the
whole idea is that you just call
functions and then this will kind of
construct
you know surely the background is kind
of constructs this graph but i think
just the fact that that's just an
example of where
you know if you're doing stuff where
you're using these are very small
primitive operations
because that's the style that you use in
tensorflow for better or worse it's very
hard to write that in kind of a
graph style it's much easier to write it
as a program so we've got two different
styles we've got the you know x equals
y plus
six you know y equals z plus two et
cetera et cetera et cetera
and that
you know that can turn into a graph
right and that's exactly what happens in
something like system modeler and so on
it's got a bunch of equations and it
turns them into a graph
and vice versa
but i believe i think thinking about
equations is too i mean this is also the
case with generalized functions but yes
what do you mean by journalist functions
i mean you're talking about it in a math
context but like this this i mean this
is the same with anything right i mean
if you if you just write a program where
you
sure you call some function it has five
outputs and a list and then you
distribute them like that and you know
et cetera i know i know but what i'm
saying is that just like we're talking
about right now making trace graphs
evaluation graphs things like that
this is a
you know this is the dependency graph
you know we should be able to go back
and forth between
a
a variable specified dependency a
variable specified thing
and the disembodied dependency graph
and my claim is that they're going to be
cases where having the disembodied
dependency graph in fact we could even
argue in some bizarre sense the physics
project is a story of basically reducing
the universe to a disembodied dependency
graph
but the thing is that generalized
programs i think you know
i i i predict that that you know we sort
of you know even with stuff like
attributes and things like that but
there's enough floppiness that actually
getting out a dependency graph a rigid
dependency graph might not always be
possible yeah that i agree that with the
actual semantics of the language that's
the case but what i'm saying is that the
going the other way around given a
dependency graph be able to evaluate the
dependency graph i mean evaluating the
dependency graph
it's very similar i would think to tree
fold that's a tree fold as a specific
case
of evaluating a rather specific i mean
that's that's that's not quite a
dependency graph that's the
you know i don't know it's something
it's something related to that
brad who can actually speak up
in audio
is mentioned directed acyclic evaluate
which is again very related
i agree directed a cyclic evaluate which
is not a great name as we've discussed
but which is the analog of tree fold for
a
dag so so i think i mean i think it's a
perfectly fine concept although i don't
think we should
design it as though it's sort of a uh
you know i mean composition is something
that's sort of used in the context of
just pure programming like it's a
programming convenience that you use to
make your code look nicer and it's on
but i i don't think this will be like
that i think this will be much more
convoluted than just writing it as a
program
and but they might have other uses
somewhere else okay so nick of course is
already evaluated so has already
you know implemented some of this so
what on earth is this
i think you've shown this before and
i've shown it before it's a it's an old
backlit for stream diagrams and
it also can be used for some functions
right for as well as a metapoint that
that the i have no idea why oh maybe you
deployed it so long ago that it doesn't
have the thing that says that has the
parenthesis that says it's like two
years ago
well
i think it needs to be brought out of
mothballs i mean it um
what the heck is that creature
i like how wiggly the lines are yeah
yeah yeah
because they're actual
yeah
vertices right each weekly
line
represents a box so it's also a graph so
it's rendered
in the calculate
you see a wire but it actually goes for
a vertex because there's actually vertex
is rendered with wires that's why it's
so wiggly
the wow it's beside the point i was
going to mention the execution open the
one
bullet point above
so related to execution thing
of string diagrams and composition of
functions
so you can specify it with tensor
notation you get a
the string diagram whatever string
diagram you want but it treat each
process as a function and you can apply
it to a list of arguments
if you if the if they're horizontally
composed they run in parallel they're
sequentially composed vertically then
the sequential exchange
you know we really should this is very
nice i mean this is this is a pattern
that just seems
it seems like we really should be able
to use this i mean i think it has a
little bit of grinding to go before
it is understandable
i mean
okay
this composite so how does this relate
to tensor multiplication
it's directly right so you can even
ask for a tensor representation for each
string diagram
so if you have a horizontal composition
it's a tensor product
more of a chronic product
if it's a sequential composition it's
just a dot product
usual tensor index contraction
yes
there's a big unification here that we
should be doing of i mean of this thing
about disembodiedly routing you know
inputs outputs
tensors is jose here can jose comment on
um
yes
on the tensorness of this of all of this
i mean um yes this makes sense we have
discussed similar things that is a birth
track rotation
and what i see here is the combination
of the contractions and the product in
between so usually we use times
but there could be contractions and
other products
say you mean you use times as opposed to
chronic products
no times are supposed to non-commutative
multiply
some other product between the tensors
okay but but in in ordinary tensor
operations
yep
the
what nick is describing as a chronicle
product if you i just take two tenses t
and u and i multiply them in the
ordinary sense of multiplication
i'm now getting confused here that is
effectively a chronic product it's t
alpha u beta
and t alpha times u beta
no so there are two different things
here one is having an outer product of
tensors without indices and the other
thing is
using indices to represent the
individual components of the tensors and
then using normal times multiplication
of those components yeah exactly okay so
t alpha
ordinary times u beta
is like an outer chronicle like product
because you've got two different indices
there whereas t
and u without indices in index free
notation you have to decide whether you
want the dot product which would be
essentially t alpha t beta oh sorry t
alpha
u ba u alpha extract right
um
and so
the point is in the index free notation
you're saying that you can
you can emulate the stringing together
of indices the knitting together of
indices by giving a string diagram that
describes in a quotes index-free way how
these different pieces of tensors should
be connected together is that right
yes that's right so you don't need any
explicit index contractions you just
represent all the linear
algebra you want with just string
diagrams
right
which is
also what happens in the quantum case et
cetera et cetera et cetera
right
so we really should we really should do
something with this we really should
make something because this is
you know us
what this is
is it's a special case of the problem of
you know graph evaluation
i think and maybe maybe brad wants to
comment on the relationship between this
and directed acyclic evaluate
well
one experiment that i tried and
failed to do is to even
make a graph that describes
matrix inversion
at an atomistic level
of just moving the
values in the rows and columns around
so
you know that's a target problem to
solve of
um something like try to get trace graph
to work for inverse
of you know say a two by two or a three
by three matrix
why is that relevant to the string
diagrams business i didn't understand
that is that is that because we can
generalize here because am i correct in
believing
that in the string diagram normally you
have
oh i see these indices it doesn't matter
whether these are there's no sense of
you know normally with indices in you
know tensors and general authority or
something like that the tensor indices
run over successive integer values
but then here you can have a any
dimension so basically you assign a
dimension to an index and that's all
that matters and also maybe a direction
by a dimension
sorry i don't understand so well if you
if you have it's like you're pointing at
a tensor that have rank five because you
have around five arrows and because
if you just look up the dimensions of a
tensor it would be like five integers
so we have a dimension assigned to each
of the
wires there okay dimension in that sense
but then then that's a tagging of the
wires and the wires better agree in
dimension if you connect the wires
together correct
yep
i wonder how that will generalize when
you don't have interdimensional wires
different question okay
right but
but connecting the wires together i i
don't know anything about these diagrams
so you have to correct me if i'm wrong
connecting the wires together is that
just going to be some sort of summation
process or something like matrix
multiplication okay
matrix multiplication is pr is i think
um
probably easier to represent as a graph
calculation
than something like the you know
gauss-jordan elimination
yeah but i don't understand why is
you're saying how do you break down
matrix inversion into a series of
operations that are essentially just
tensor contraction like operations
let's say you have an in uh three by
three matrix
that that essentially is
um nine inputs that come with some sort
of structure
and then at the end of the calculation
if you inverse it or even if you just do
a b c d exactly
yeah and i tried to trace graph that it
was
it didn't it's not useful because
because since it's internal code
yeah
right let's let's zoom back out again
but by the way look one one conclusion
is we need to make string diagrams be a
you know something like string diagrams
our version of string diagrams which is
basically graphical
graphical variable knitting
you know graphical the graphical
generalization of composition
which again is surely related to
directory basic click evaluate
could you could you put in in zoom chat
could you put the link to direct today
click evaluate
brad
hello brad
or anybody else
somebody put the link to direct thank
you
that is not a good basic example look at
how complicated that is
what is a minimal example of this i mean
this is
you're taking a graph
and just like with treefold
where you are
am i right
can you say the the basic minimal
example is just that
um path count is linear recurrence
and so we make these graphs where
basically it's just doing that once the
fibonacci sequence
okay
and that's really this that graph that's
specified there is
one of the simplest
easy graphs i mean if it was just a
straight path graph nothing but this
function if it was you know the correct
design would surely be
you feed it
i don't understand you feed it a graph
on the rules
and what does it output it outputs
tagging on the graph right it outputs a
value so so what this is just like our
trees have payloads at every node right
we do not currently have a payloaded
graph
does that make sense
uh but we do have the vertex weights
that we i understand that i understand i
understand so we can but we don't have
something which is a
a payload first i mean trees are a very
payload first kind of structure
but we can imagine a graph
okay so this is a case okay what is the
relationship between this this thing
which is
oh my gosh the the
at every step
it is
going to one new node is that correct
no it's got it's it's no this function
takes all kinds of hair
when it's
you know this is kind of like a rough
draft honestly it worked for what it was
meant to do but in the next version
it what it probably will do is step
through levels of the foliation of the
directed a psychograph
okay which is deeply related to
something you weren't um okay what is
this so ian is sending us
this is an identity between treefold and
directed acyclic evaluate
so directed acyclic evaluate is starting
from
all of the roots
of a graph like in a dag you can have
more than one
uh initial vertex
right yes
you're accumulating a value down to all
of the sinks or or whatever all of the
leaves
right and there's a slightly different
syntax
from tree fold
but so there's so wait a minute so are
you saying that
you can
sort of con from it from a dag
you can construct a tree
i mean a dag can be unrolled
so this is like
this is like restricting directed
acyclic evaluate two trees
i see okay okay fine yes i understand
that so it's a it has multiple roots
in general
um
so in tree two four five six and seven
are the leaves directed acyclic evaluate
in order to get this to line up you have
to reverse graph of the tree because
those are whatever
yeah
whatever but i see the correspondence
but i mean and
the main point here is
this concept of a graph with payloads
which seems to be very related to string
diagrams is that true
in other words
reports
right okay so so what we don't have here
is
graphs
with payloads and yes we do partially
have that through vertex weights
and with ports
right where um and string diagrams
obviously as in next picture
have ports
i mean that's the whole idea those those
tensor indices there now as i recall in
the in in the you know penrose tensor
notation aren't there elaborate ways of
indicating symmetry between uh between
those different edges
jose maybe you can say or somebody else
yes yes there are so depending on the if
you can
say
have an object that is symmetric under
swapping of two indices then you assign
a shape to that object that is symmetric
i see
right so if yeah so it's important to
have ways of identifying which port is
the first one and which one is the
second one
unless it happens to be symmetric in
which case it doesn't actually matter
exactly and then you want a shape that
that height which one is the first and
the second
and what is that shape
um i don't know for example imagine that
something that is fully symmetric all of
them are equivalent then you want
something like a circle because it
doesn't matter which one is the first
oh you mean that you draw this diagram
instead of drawing that as a box you
draw it as a circle where those
connectors come onto the circle
exactly
for example in this case in which the
the left shape is different than the
right shape is some sort of trapezoid
you have a an a way of orienting
yourself
so you always know which one is which
one
yeah there's some improved shapes here
because if you make this in a symmetric
shape there's a meaning
what it means to transpose this tensor
to make an adjoint of tensor it's
basically flipping around the shape
in a horizontal
vertical axis or just rotating it
okay but the main thing is the main the
concept of the disembodied evaluation
the disembodied
we shouldn't call it evaluation graph
the disembodied kind of
function knitting graph
um
and uh seth is commenting that directed
a simple evaluate might be useful for
probabilistic graphical models
which are important in causal inference
yeah i mean we we keep on looking at
things like this
um
after i did that big long discussion
with judea pearl we
looked at this even some more
um uh
there's a whole bunch of ideas that are
connected
um
you know
this
probabilistic graphical models is i
think a
you know what we have with things like
token event graphs and causal graphs and
so on are much more industrial scale
versions of the same type of idea
um where you know in probably graphical
models every
every what we would call event
has a name and a significance it has a
you know it has a it's it's a thing like
it's
you know some
some
thing you identify in the world whereas
we have these much more industrial scale
things where we're generating giant
causal graphs and so on but i think it's
the same type of idea and i think yes
it's true that some evaluation of causal
graphs is going to be the same type of
story
all right let's return to our
again i want to make sure that we have
this uh
sort of
i mean this is
we have this way
i mean again we're going to need this
this whole discussion graphs with
payloads and ports
i think that probably should be broken
off as a separate discussion
and then
uh once we have that
the notion of sort of evaluating a graph
is closely related to
um
uh
directed acyclic evaluate
becomes something we should talk about
okay let's go back to our our
naming problem here
of
this is a splitting
see i don't know what the metaphor is
come on guys we got we got to be able to
do this
what is the right
kind of concept metaphor you've got two
functions to be applied to one thing
what about the name map into for the
version that takes a level spec i put
some code in chat
forget the level spec the level spec is
yet another
you know bizarre and complicated as
opposed to the version that's like
construct
the varargs version i think if we had a
verax version it would need a different
name i think yes
yeah i mean not just like if we had both
of them would be different i mean if
that was the version we were going with
we would name it differently
but what the heck is going on here this
is the this has its arguments in the
opposite order
yeah so this this has the arguments in
the same order as map
no it doesn't
what
doesn't it doesn't proposal
i think i think it does in the sense
that the list is in the second argument
but it doesn't in the sense that that
the functions go in the first argument
of map so it depends on which one of
those you take to be the yeah i think
the function should be so the idea of
this is that you're mapping something
into the sub expressions rather than
around the sub expressions which is what
map does
yeah i mean it doesn't make a certain
amount of sense it's i'm not sure i'm
not sure i i agree it's superior but i'm
it's not a priority obvious to me that
it isn't superior
okay what are we really doing what we're
really doing is
we're taking a list of functions
and
applying them
to an argument
i'm sure we've had a playlist before
right and the only i mean i i think the
main argument against this is that this
isn't apply in the sense of apply and
since this is something that's so
closely to the map apply family that's a
potential
how about how about map functions
say it again map functions
with an s on the end
there isn't a map either
there's nothing mappy about it well it's
mapping the functions it's not mapping
over values
that required too much explanation i
think
um i mean i think map is the most
analogous function
especially when you consider the
behavior like where where
you know instead of uh
you know instead of giving a list of f
and g you give some other thing you know
no it's either
g it's reversed map
right this is why someone made the joke
the other day that that that
we should call it pam
for that reason yes
[Laughter]
next we'll have car and cutter
yeah
okay
i also like the idea of a variant of map
and i think i i suggested long ago dual
map or commap but you phoned them to
mathematica
the come up idea is related to what nick
was saying before
this is some sort of cobalian version
do you think anybody would understand
that i mean
you know it's one of these things where
we get the opportunity to educate people
about a small number of concepts
do we want to pick this one as one of
them
so i i think i think i would use it
without with lowercase m and i mean i'm
thinking about map a map is a name that
we have to learn too
i agree i agree
so so either we find a variant or a
completely different name or a
combination of two functions that
imitate this one
but all possibilities like
through
construct it is very complicated
right i mean i suppose given that one
implementation is literally map of
construct right we could call it map
construct but i i don't know that that
actually helps anything
i don't think it helps something i mean
it's um
do we think co-map versus dual map
i mean maybe joel map
i think
although dual map sounds like it's doing
two maps at once yeah
yeah i thought about multi-map but i
think that's also no we don't want to
touch the multi-family right i kind of i
kind of like co-map
with or without the capital m
tragically without the capital m i think
it looks too weird with the capital m
and co doesn't mean anything on its own
yeah but co-map has a certain
i don't know why but but it
i'm sort of it's just a very weird word
it's kind of
it's not obvious how to read it even
no
com ap
anti-map
reverse map
that's not right
yeah i've suggested that a few minutes
ago
anti-map just seems crazy i mean
the
contra mark
you know right i thought you said
counter map which is
another good latin derived one
um
who would ever understand this
the one sentence description of this
thing
look the one sentence description is
you know blah blah blah of f g comma x
you know
this is how we describe it gives
you know f of x g of x
right i mean i i think if this was in
version one this would probably have
some weird name like a cross or
something like it would just pick some
some verb or preposition or something
but but honestly i think that's you know
a lot of those names like through are
not good names because it's just totally
indecipherable
across
that has the applied
you just i mean when we're adding apply
the apply actually means nothing it's
just that there's function application
involved which is the case with almost
all of these functions
construct across
what
construct list
again no this is this
it doesn't return if we're having the
version that isn't vera i think
construct is misleading
oh yes
probably yeah
god i can't believe he's being spent
what about the red heads
so if it
the thing i would expect thread heads to
be is exactly through
which is that you know i have it as the
head
yeah right
yeah that's what we should all right so
we rename through thread heads and we
break through be this function
well would through even be the right
name for this function
oh through is the wrong name for
everything like it's just
it's a useless name
all right what would you expect to see
um
what do you think of the proposed usage
message i put in chat
no way but we've got a bunch of other
suggestions people are not making
verbally like map first
sounds that person is completely wrong
right yeah exactly that sounds like
select first
i do like co-map
i guess one i guess one question we
haven't explicitly discussed is
does the first argument have to be a
list or can it be no
okay
stuff is a different rapper returns that
rapper again
yep right same semantics as map and also
the same is through except that you
don't have to apply the object
which means you can do nice things like
if you give an association through can't
work with an association because the
moment you apply it it'll run
so in this case you're saying that
comapp
could
take an association as the first
argument and then
this will so wait a second so what does
this do
if we say map what do i
remember what we called it here head map
of an association
a goes to x b goes to y
and we are
and give it two
then you'll get a the association a goes
to
oh yeah
that's the correct thing
god i need to understand this what is
this doing now
it's just taking the x and it's applying
it to two and it's taking the y it's
applying it to two
right because it's taking all the
elements at the first level of the
association right because that rule
isn't really there it's that
right it's just yeah right so the thing
to do to do a practical case just write
this just instead of you know a write
quotes mean and for the function right
mean
or like you know average goes to mean
and variance goes to standard deviation
or whatever now what's annoying is if we
don't have the var args case
then if two is a list
this wouldn't work
no no but then what you can do would be
to double the wrapped list right
well no no no if you don't have the
varargs case the list will just be fed
in exactly like it is here and if you
want to do the kind of vera behavior you
just map apply over your association
here
what
you'd have to but
i don't think
right you don't have the borrower's case
then this shouldn't work it right yeah
there's an example if you open the level
spec section right below this
the
yeah the head that last example with the
head map um
right so that that that's how you
implement bear arguments right there if
you don't actually have their arms that
wouldn't really work if you're dealing
with uh stuff that holds code though it
would be kind of annoying to have to
work around that
yeah what do you mean stuff that holds
so the operator form of apply
uh
i mean let's say apply of hold form
right you can't
you can't take that
operator form and then apply it to one
plus one and get a whole form of one
plus one it'll evaluate
well but head map already doesn't have
you know
doesn't already already doesn't have
attributes like that right so well yeah
but i mean you can always pass on
evaluated stuff to functions like this
so you can
you know you can pass unevaluated to map
you can
or whatever but once you're dealing with
that operator form that that's not going
to work anymore
yeah
then you would have to to map function
across your
your thing and you know give it the
appropriate attributes
yeah yeah and that's the part that that
is kind of painful maybe there should be
a separate co-map thread
that's like map thread
yes i mean if we're going with co-map
um
okay so we've got co-map
i'm beginning to like this co-map of fgx
okay and then we'd have co-map thread
right
which then turns this into
f of x comma y comma g of x comma y
right i mean this is just
is it
is it just doing an outer then
no it's doing it uh yeah i guess
i mean really what this is as you've
been saying
is apply f apply g
co-mapped onto that
right and the only cases where it's not
equivalent are when
i guess when you use unevaluated
i can't really think of any other cases
well so if the first argument had like
the head hold
then you'd you'd be co-mapping a literal
apply of f and it wouldn't evaluate
because of the whole
no but again there needs to be an
evaluated in the second argument for
that to make a difference right
because otherwise the second argument is
going to evaluate
anyway and so it doesn't matter you know
if the
if there's an unevaluated for the second
argument
sorry
what was that i didn't hear all of it
type a co-map of hold of f comma g
or maybe head map so we can see what it
does
just some
no list inside the hole
well that's an implementation
yeah but well
if you know let's say you fix the
implementation still if you had apply of
f and apply of g you'd have a literal
apply of f there
still
it's not going to immediately evaluate
the function
yeah
look if we're going to call it co-map
it's got to have the same argument
structure as map with level specs
which then probably means the co-map
thread has to be done
i want to think about where the thread
is the right
name though because thread kind of
implies you have two parallel lists but
i don't think there are any parallel
lists involved and what about co-map
apply
yeah that seems like yeah i think that's
that's a better name
and is this
is this equivalent of map apply
is this the code the dual of map apply
that sounds reasonable
so map apply will do
that
okay let me just understand if you say
we're used to saying map f over the list
abc
so we would now say co-map the list fg
over x
right
and then we can confusingly have the
infix of backslash at or
at backslash or something
or maybe it's co-map x under
list fg
instead of over
you mean you state the arguments in
different order even though now he's
just suggesting that in in the disc in
the informal description rather than
saying you co-map f g over x you would
say you co-map fg under x because we're
now going to stop with it
you map functions over arguments but you
co-map
you know functions under arguments
because up is down because it's code i
know i know i know i know
all right we should wrap up here um
i think we let let us proceed with come
up and come up apply that's right and
actually
it does seem like co-map apply is really
the duel of map apply because it's the
same concept but instead of the list
being around all the different sets of
arguments it's just around all the
different functions
okay
is someone who understands snap apply
going to
agree or disagree
well i'm it's not clear to me what we've
decided on the
argument structure of comac
co map apply
okay so that's list fg
comma the list and
it's the equivalent of
map apply onto f and g
except that it deals with the holding
correctly and so on
right and no level spec yeah
all right right so yeah so i think i
think apply yes then i agree with
christopher's assessment
which does encourage the name co-map
in mathematics
when we say there's a mapping
and it's a little weird this is a little
different yet again than the
mathematical meaning of a mapping
not the map is the most spectacular you
know mathematical
mapping thing right is there is there a
uh i mean there must be some area of
math where there's a concept of a
command
i'm sure there is uh
if not i mean
sometimes the the inverse map is
referred to as the co-map right
especially when you view it as
going
you know to to to sets right
um
yeah it's usually
right
but the notion of a co-functor does
exist right
absolutely
well then it's probably the right thing
uh there is a thing called co-map and
haskell apparently
which does what
uh
usually
it means there's arrows reversed
yeah actually i think co-map is is just
basically the functor map it's just a
it's just map i don't know why they
all right we should wrap up here
thanks a lot everybody
and see you all soon